[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers hallo
und guten Abend ihnen allen ungefähr
alles an der aktuellen Reise des
Bundeskanzlers ist speziell
gewöhnungsbedürftig auf ganz vielen
Ebenen darf ein westlicher
Regierungschef den gerade erneut im Amt
zementierten Alleinherrscher in Peking
ausgerechnet jetzt beehren oder muss er
das gerade zu tun schon aus deutschem
Interesse und weil China großen Einfluss
hat auf Russland wir sprechen dazu
gleich ausführlich
roter Teppich und Schutzanzug schon der
Empfang vor dem vip-terminal des
Flughafens in Peking ist bemerkenswert
der Kanzler hat drei PCR-Tests
absolviert er fliegt zweimal um die
halbe Welt für ein paar Stunden vor Ort
China ist Partner und Rivale zugleich
steht so im Berliner Koalitionsvertrag
allerdings ohne dass dabei stünde was
denn das konkret heißen soll für die
Politik und so wird jeder Besuch bei
Deutschlands wichtigstem Handelspartner
zu einem schwierigen Balanceakt aus
Peking berichtet Miriam Steimer meine
Damen und Herren es ist gut und richtig
dass ich heute hier im Peking bin
dieser erste Satz von Olaf Scholz bei
der Pressekonferenz zeigt wie viel
Kritik an seiner Reise er aus
Deutschland mitgebracht hat doch von
vorne
bei der Ankunft trägt China die Angst
zur Schau dass die Gäste das Coronavirus
im Gepäck haben könnten der
regierungsflieger wird während des
kanzlertagesausflugs in Südkorea geparkt
1000 Kilometer entfernt das ist wohl
einfacher als mit China über
quarantäne-regeln für die Crew zu
verhandeln willkommen im Null College
China
die chinesische Staatspropaganda hat ein
Lieblingsbild vom deutschen Kanzler zehn
Mal wiederholt sie das identische Bild
seines nickens während er den Worten von
Staatschef hier den Ping lauscht China
freut sich außerdem über Scholz
Gastgeschenk den cosco-deal mit dem
Hamburger Hafen
es läuft nach Chinas Spielregeln im
Goldenen Saal gibt hi zu Scholz Ehren
ein willkommensbankett es ist der Ort an
dem hier vor wenigen Tagen seine neue
Führungsmannschaft vorstellte
ausschließlich mit loyalen Kadern
besetzt beim Parteitag der
Kommunistischen Partei baute er den ein
parteienstart zur einmann-diktatur um
Scholz ist der erste westliche Besuch
danach das persönliche Treffen sei
wichtig auch wegen des Kriegs in der
Ukraine und er verkündet einen Erfolg
staatspräsidentie und ich sind uns einig
atomare Drohgebärden sind
unverantwortlich und brandgefährlich
mit dem Einsatz von Atomwaffen würde
Russland eine Linie überschreiten die
die Staatengemeinschaft gemeinsam
gezogen hat
Scholz trifft auch den scheidenden
Regierungschef für den skiab März kein
Platz mehr in seiner Führungsmannschaft
hat für chinesische Verhältnisse
distanziert der sich ungewöhnlich offen
von Russlands Vorgehen in der Ukraine
wir hoffen alle auf ein baldiges Ende
der ukraine-krise es ist an der Zeit
beide Seiten zufriedensgesprächen zu
bewegen
Scholz spricht Taiwan an und auch die
Verletzung der Menschenrechte er betont
dass die universell gültig sein auch für
Minderheiten die Umsetzung dieser Rechte
anzumahnen
zum Beispiel in der Provinz 10 Yang ist
deswegen keine Einmischung in innere
Angelegenheiten
[Musik]
geht es ums Geschäft er reist mit einer
Wirtschaftsdelegation und verkündet die
Zulassung des biontech-impfstoffs in
China zunächst allerdings nur für
Ausländer die hier leben
bringen wir Mikro hoothari dazu er ist
Direktor des mercator-instituts für
China Studien seine
Forschungsschwerpunkte Chinas
Außenpolitik und die Beziehungen zu
Europa willkommen zurück im heute
journalgant
schönen guten Abend Herr hohe Tari was
würden Sie sagen was waren jetzt anders
bei dem Besuch von Olaf Scholz
vielleicht im Vergleich zum letzten
Besuch von Angela Merkel in Peking
nun das war kein herzlicher Besuch der
Besuch fand statt unter sehr schwierigen
Bedingungen alle Seiten haben mit Mühe
ihre eigenen Interessen gewahrt insofern
kein Fest es war ein Besuch der das
Minimalziel erreicht hat ein commitment
der führenden Peking mit Blick auf die
Krise in der Ukraine und insofern kann
der Kanzler hier durchaus kleine Erfolge
vorweisen aber es ist nichts was wofür
man sich zu Hause feiern lassen kann
reden wir über einen Punkt der doch
heraus stark Chinas Machthaber warnt
jetzt sehr deutlich vor einer Eskalation
im ukrainekrieg er sagt er sei mit
Russlands atomarem Säbelrasseln nicht
einverstanden ist das ein diplomatischer
Durchbruch den der Bundeskanzler da
erreicht hat
nun es zeigt wie Verfahren die Situation
ist dass etwas was eigentlich
selbstverständlich sein sollte jetzt als
diplomatischer Durchbruch antizipiert
wird es ist klar dass die führenden
Peking selbstverständlich vor solchen
Aktivitäten waren müsste das hat sie
zuletzt auch in einem Statement der der
ständig Mitglieder des der Vereinten
Nationen im Januar getan jetzt wurde das
noch mal wiederholt das ist wichtig es
ist wichtig für Europa insofern ein
kleiner Erfolg aber noch mal es sollte
eine Selbstverständlichkeit sein wie
wichtig ist denn so ein Besuch für
chinas Führung ist das denn an sich
schon so quasi eine Huldigung wie im
Vorfeld kritisiert wurde
ich glaube das ist zu viel gesagt aber
es ist klar dass der Besuch sehr
willkommen ist er ist choreografiert in
einer Serie von Besuchen ausländischer
Staatschef Scholz schlichter heraus als
Vertreter eines demokratischen Staates
und insofern ein Signal dort für die
Führung gesetzt in Peking zu sagen wir
sind noch im Geschäft der Westen
vertraut uns noch wir sind nicht alleine
und insbesondere natürlich gegenüber
Europa in klaren Punkt gesetzt
Deutschland spielt hier mit uns wenn der
Bundeskanzler wie heute in Peking
geschehen dann sagt für Deutschland
haben Menschenrechte universelle
Gültigkeit welche Wirkung hat denn das
hat das ganz konkret auch positive
Folgen für Menschen
denen ihre Menschenrechte genommen sind
in China
und das zeichnet ist wichtig wir können
die genaue Folgen nicht abschätzen aber
erstmal perlt das ab an der Führung da
ist wenig zu erwarten an konkreten
Ergebnissen die Führung wird das mit
genervten Gesten wahrnehmen aber in der
Sache ändert sich da erstmal
grundsätzlich nicht das ist also vor
allem fürs eigene Gewissen verstehst du
da richtig fürs deutsche gute Gewissen
nun es ist wichtig auch für die
internationale Gemeinschaft an diesem
Thema dran zu bleiben öffentlich zu sein
Dinge zu signalisieren nur so kann eine
gemeinsame Position noch
aufrechterhalten werden aber
selbstverständlich geht es da erstmal
darum zu sagen dass es unser Werte kann
und unsere Position die Hoffnung auf
Veränderung in China scheint mir da sehr
verfehlt Herr rothaare wir reden gleich
noch weiter gucken aber jetzt erstmal
was passiert wenn ein langjähriger
Partner plötzlich zum Gegner wird das
erleben wir ja alle gerade überdeutlich
ich sage nur 40 Milliarden Euro Verlust
beim gasimporteur Juniper der voll auf
Russland gesetzt hatte Vergleich
verglichen mit dem China Business der
deutschen Wirtschaft wirken selbst diese
Probleme plötzlich ganz klein die
gegenseitige Abhängigkeit Deutschland
china ist in manchen Branchen längst
systemrelevant sprich ein Ende der
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen kann sich niemand
vorstellen im Gegenteil BASF und VW etwa
bauen sie weiter kräftig aus Oliver
deuka mit mehr dazu
Druckgussteile aus Aluminium und
Magnesium darauf ist die Firma GA Röders
aus dem niedersächsischen Soltau
spezialisiert die Grundstoffe kommen aus
China
die Abhängigkeit zu China ist sehr groß
da einige Metalle besonders Magnesium
nur noch in China praktisch hergestellt
werden wenn wir dieses Magnesium nicht
bekommen können wir unsere Teile für die
Automobilindustrie den Flugzeugbau oder
die Medizintechnik nicht mehr herstellen
nur ein Beispiel der Abhängigkeit
Deutschlands von China vor allem
verarbeitete Rohstoffe oder
Zwischenprodukte kommen aus dem Reich
der Mitte bei Rohstoffen wie den
Seltenen Erden haben wir eine
Importabhängigkeit von über 90 Prozent
und auch bei anderen Rohstoffen die für
den Energiewende oder für die
Digitalisierung benötigt werden oder für
die E-Mobilität wie
Germanium Gallium oder Graphit für die
Batterien haben wir eine relativ hohe
Abhängigkeit von über 50 bis 80 Prozent
aus China
abhängig von Rohstoffen aus China aber
auch vom dortigen Markt
die Handelsbilanz zwischen den Ländern
betrug im vergangenen Jahr 246
Milliarden Euro Waren im Wert von 103
Milliarden Euro das sind 7,5% des
gesamten deutschen Exportes gegen nach
China
einzelne deutsche Unternehmen
erwirtschaften dort einen guten Teil
ihrer Gewinne rund 40% der mvw-konzern
produzierten Fahrzeuge werden in China
verkauft in einem Pressestatement heißt
es unsere Folge in China haben ganz
maßgeblich zur Stärkung unserer
deutschen Standort beigetragen anteilige
Gewinne aus China haben in Deutschland
Arbeitsplätze und Einkommen gesichert
wir wollen in China wachsen zusätzliche
Marktanteile gewinnen würde dieser Markt
aber wegbrechen hätte nicht nur VW ein
Problem um die Abhängigkeit von von
China zu reduzieren braucht es
natürlich Diversifizierung in erster
Linie also mehr Handel treiben mit
anderen Ländern
das ist teilweise Aufgabe der
Unternehmen in manchen Bereichen
brauchst politische unterstütz dabei
Rohstoffen da sprechen wir über
rohstoffpartnerschaften mit anderen
Staaten etwa Lateinamerika oder Asien
Deutschland ist abhängig von China aber
China braucht auch Deutschland braucht
den Westen braucht Märkte mit
zahlungskräftigen Kunden
der China-Experte mikohotari ist weiter
bei uns beide Seiten haben wir gerade
gelernt brauchen einander und tun sich
gleichzeitig immer schwerer miteinander
jetzt war heute bei Olaf Scholz auch
wieder eine schwergewichtige
Wirtschaftsdelegation mit dabei in
Peking ist das denn für die immer noch
so business as usual
nun ist eine riskante Wette die die
Bundesregierung aber natürlich
insbesondere die großen Unternehmen dort
machen auf einen stabiles und
erfolgreiches China in dem Geschäfte
weiter so laufen sollen wie sie das in
der Vergangenheit getan haben und das
ist nicht selbstverständlich und
keineswegs ausgemacht an vielen Stellen
sind diese Unternehmen unter heftigen
Wettbewerbsdruck an anderen Stellen
stehen sie vor einem Risiko auch der
politischen
Schocks die durchaus mit der neuen
Führung in China verbunden werden müssen
ganz besonders natürlich im Hintergrund
schwielt dieses Szenario was im Falle
eines größeren taiwan-konfliktes
passieren würden und wir sind in einer
Welt in der geopolitischen Spannung
zunehmen und Unternehmen müssen sich
hier auf deutlich größere Risiken
einstellen man hat aber den Eindruck
dass es Unternehmen gibt in Deutschland
die diese Abhängigkeit von China
überhaupt gar nicht mehr reduzieren
können
es ist eine schwieriges Geschäft gerade
in einer Zeit in der die Weltwirtschaft
in den nächsten Jahren in Europa
insbesondere nicht stark wachsen wird
suchen die Unternehmen natürlich nach
jedem jeglichem Wachstumsmotor den sie
noch finden China ist im Moment selbst
in einer schweren Krise insofern ist das
eine Rückversicherung aber in China das
zwei drei Prozent wächst ist eben immer
noch mehr als das was in Europa zu
erwarten ist insofern eine schwierige
Angelegenheit jetzt wurde noch mal ein
deutliches Signal gesetzt dass die
Wirtschaft hier stark auf China setzt
kann in Deutschland die Verflechtung mit
China allein der Wirtschaft überlassen
sowie in der Vergangenheit häufig und
die Welt quasi wie ein Kaufmann
betrachten auch aus politischer Sicht
nein das wären ein Fehler in diesen
Zeiten kann die Bundesregierung sich
hier nicht zurückziehen und sozusagen
Unternehmen ihrem Schicksal überlassen
zum Teil brauchen Sie natürlich auch die
Unterstützung das ist das eine auch in
China im übrigen aber dann insbesondere
natürlich mit Blick auf die Frage wohin
kann diversifiziert werden und dann
vielleicht noch viel kritischer und
sensibler derzeit woher kommen
eigentlich die kritischen und sensiblen
Inputs die Importe in die deutsche und
europäische Wirtschaft hier gibt es ganz
klare Aufgabe auch für die Politik dafür
zu sorgen dass wir hier besser
aufgestellt sind wirtschaftliche Mittel
einsetzen um damit politische Ziele zu
erreichen darin ist China ja nun
wirklich Meister überall auf der Welt in
Afrika zum Beispiel hat denn Deutschland
so eine geo-ökonomische Strategie auch
wir sind weit davon entfernt die
relevanten Ministerien das
Außenministerium das Ministerium für
Wirtschaft und Klima Arbeiten nicht eng
an einem Strang zusammen ganz besonders
natürlich nicht mit dem Bundeskanzleramt
also insofern dass es eine große Aufgabe
die dann noch vor Deutschland steht im
zusammen in der Zusammenarbeit mit
Europa hier eine echte
außenwirtschaftliche Offensive
vorzulegen der Bundeskanzler und seine
Delegation sind auf dem Rückflug zurück
nach Berlin mit Tarifa bei uns in der
Sendung um all das zu analysieren ganz
herzlichen Dank auch heute Abend wieder
danke Ihnen
und jetzt weitere wichtige Nachrichten
von diesem Freitag in der Übersicht mit
Diana an Tag 2 das Treffens der G7
außenministerinnen und Minister in
Münster stand Iran im Zentrum in ihrem
gemeinsamen Abschluss Dokument
verurteilten die G7 den brutalen und
unverhältnismäßigen Einsatz von Gewalt
gegen friedliche Demonstranten und
Kinder die Runde verlangte außerdem von
Teheran Waffenlieferungen an Russland
einzustellen konkrete zusätzliche
Sanktionen gegen Iran wurden nicht
verkündet mit Partnern aus Afrika
Sprachen die G7 über die zukünftige
Zusammenarbeit
Bundesjustizminister Buschmann hat der
Ukraine Unterstützung für einen
EU-Beitritt versprochen bei einem Besuch
in Kiew sagte er man werde dem Land
dabei helfen die nötigen
rechtsstaatlichen Standards zu erfüllen
beide Seiten unterzeichneten ein
Arbeitsprogramm zur Zusammenarbeit im
Justizbereich gemeinsam mit Kiews
Bürgermeister Klitschko ließ sich
Buschmann Kriegsschäden in der
Hauptstadt zeigen der Minister erklärte
das Land auch bei der Aufklärung von
Kriegsverbrechen zu unterstützen
unser Generalbundesanwalt sammelt
Beweise zu Kriegsverbrechen in der
Ukraine und damit wollen wir einerseits
den Internationalen Strafgerichtshof
unterstützen wir wollen auch die
ukrainischen Ermittlungsbehörden
unterstützen aber wenn Täter nach
Deutschland kämen wenn wir ihrer dort
habhaft würden können wir Sie auch in
Deutschland vor Gericht stellen
die Ampel hat sich auf Änderungen
angeplanten Bürgergeld geeinigt und will
damit eine Blockade der Union im
Bundesrat verhindern so sollen die
Heizkosten in den ersten zwei Jahren des
Bezugs nicht mehr unbegrenzt sondern nur
noch in angemessener Höhe übernommen
werden zudem soll das Schonvermögen
genauer geprüft werden durch eine
Selbstauskunft der Bundestag will am
kommenden Donnerstag über das Bürgergeld
abstimmen soll Anfang 2023 Hartz IV
ersetzen
die ostdeutschen Bundesländer wollen im
Kampf gegen Rechtsextremismus künftig
enger zusammenarbeiten und planen dazu
die Einrichtung eines expertentreffens
darauf haben sich die Innenminister der
Länder in Erfurt geeinigt Thema waren
dabei auch die wöchentlich
stattfindenden Demonstrationen gegen die
Energie und corona-politik diese würden
teilweise von Rechtsextremen Strukturen
unterwandert erklärte Thüringens
Innenminister Meyer
seit Wochen hält Nordkorea immer wieder
Raketentests ab nun reagierte Südkorea
mit einer scharfen Antwort nach
nordkoreanischen Luft waffenmanövern
ließ Südkorea insgesamt 80 Kampfjets
aufsteigen zur Stunde beschäftigt sich
zudem der UN-Sicherheitsrat in New York
mit dem Konflikt bei seinem Besuch in
Seoul verurteilt Bundespräsident
Steinmeier Nordkoreas jüngste
Raketentests und forderte ernsthafte
Verhandlungen über den Abbau des
nuklearen Raketenprogramms
wenn Sie noch einen Beweis brauchen wie
abenteuerlich absurd es in unserer Welt
zugeht hier ist er die
Nachrichtenagentur Reuters meldet der
türkische Staatspräsident Recep type
Erdogan habe sich als Vermittler
Angeboten im Streit um die geplante
Gebühr für den blauen
verifizierungshaken bei Twitter
möglicherweise ist ihnen Twitter egal
und vom blauen Häkchen haben sie auch
noch nie etwas gehört interessant bleibt
dennoch was ich da gerade abspielt seit
der reichste Mann der Welt den
einflussreichsten Kurznachrichtendienst
der Welt gekauft hat und jetzt mit
irratischen Aktionen von sich reden
macht und mit ganz bitteren Elon Musk
will offenbar die Hälfte der Twitter
Belegschaft vor die Tür setzen unter dem
Hashtag one-team sind erschütternde
Geschichten zu lesen aktuell auf Twitter
Benjamin Daniel und die Details
scheiß auf Musk scheiß auf Gier schreibt
ein Anwohner auf den Bürgersteig vor dem
Twitter Hauptquartier in San Francisco
sollte von Leuten geführt werden die für
gute Inhalte stehen und nicht von jenen
die das meiste Geld haben twitter hat
sich noch nie so richtig für seine
Nutzer interessiert und jetzt wird wohl
alles noch viel schlimmer werden
neuer Tag neuer Paukenschlag neue
Profilbeschreibung seit kurzem nennt
sich Elon Musk Betreiber der Twitter
beschwerde-hotline passend dazu ein
Kinderfoto von ihm mit spielzeugtelefon
mask scheint seinen fragwürdigen Humor
nicht suchen zu müssen im Sturm des
Unverständnisses der ihm zur Zeit
entgegenschlägt tausenden Mitarbeitern
ließ er per Mail ausrichten dass sie
gefeuert sind oder sie wurden erst gar
nicht informiert wie Simon Berlin dessen
Zugänge einfach gesperrt wurden
besonders Leute mit Arbeitsvisum stehen
jetzt große Ängste aus je nach
Aufenthaltsstatus kann es bedeuten dass
wenn sie nicht ganz bald einen neuen Job
finden dass sie ihr langjähriges zuhause
und das Land einfach verlassen müssen
das ist wirklich furchtbar
furchtbar empfinden viele vor allem die
Art und Weise wie der reichste Mann der
Welt Menschen auf die Straße setzt
deshalb haben mehrere ehemalige
Mitarbeiter bereits Klage eingereicht
sie werfen Musk vor gegen kalifornisches
Arbeitsrecht verstoßen zu haben
ein Unternehmen wie Twitter das so in
der Öffentlichkeit steht hat sicher kein
Interesse an einem solchen Prozess die
Mitarbeiter drängen auf eine Lösung dass
sie damit abschließen und nach vorne
schauen können denn ihre Jobs bei
Twitter werden nicht zurückkommen also
ist es in beiderseitigem Interesse eine
Lösung zu finden
eine Lösung wird sich Musk wohl auch für
die Werbetreibenden überlegen müssen er
will die Redefreiheit auf der Plattform
radikal ausdehnen viele befürchten
weniger Moderationen mehr
Falschinformationen zahlreiche
Unternehmen haben daher Ihre Werbung
ausgesetzt Musk geäußerte sich vor
wenigen Stunden dazu
[Musik]
das ist ein Angriff auf den ersten
Verfassungszusatz auf die Redefreiheit
twitter ist dringend auf die
Werbetreibenden angewiesen und
Aktivisten setzen Sie unter Druck damit
sie die Redefreiheit unterdrücken das
ist doch nicht richtig
manche Mitarbeiter die heute gefeuert
wurden sagten sie seien erleichtert
gewesen sie hätten es sich ohnehin nicht
vorstellen können für diesen Chef zu
arbeiten und so geht wohl noch mehr
Leuten jenes durch den Kopf was nun vor
der twitter-zentrale auf dem Boden steht
gerade wurde es schon angesprochen
Twitter laufen die Werbekunden weg wegen
des radikalen Umbaus der Plattform und
das wollen wir uns jetzt noch mal
genauer anschauen Frank Wiedmann denn
das betrifft auch Deutschland der
Volkswagenkonzern will erstmal keine
Werbung mehr schalten ja die Wolfsburger
sind ein gebranntes Kind nach dem
zuletzt ungewollt eine Online-Anzeige
auf einem rechten us-nachrichten-portal
erschienen und an anderer Stelle einen
als rassistisch empfundenes Werbevideo
von VW gesendet wurde hat der Konzern
seine Abläufe intern überprüft achtet
inzwischen sehr viel genauer darauf in
welchem Umfall fällt es Online Werbung
schaltet und deswegen wundert es nicht
zuvor hatten bereits mit General Motors
und dem us-lebensmittelkonzern General
Mills 2 weitere Schwergewichte Ihre
Werbung bei Twitter gestoppt deswegen
wundert es also nicht dass nun auch
Volkswagen diesen Schritt gewählt hat
vorübergehend wie es heißt hat dies aber
gleichzeitig sämtlichen konzerntöchtern
wie Audi oder Porsche auch empfohlen
Twitter trifft das an in seiner
empfindlichsten Stelle des Unternehmen
erwirtschaftet 90 Prozent seiner
Einnahmen mit Werbung gab es für
maßkräuter aber auch noch an ganz
anderer Front Gegenwind und zwar bei
Tesla was war da los ja die Aktie des
e-autobaus ist heute deutlich zeitweise
über sechs Prozent gefallen am Markt
gibt es unterschiedliche
Interpretationen die einen sagen die
Aktie hat so deutlich nachgegeben weil
Tesla überraschend die Preise für seine
Autos gesenkt hat also zumindest in
China geht da etwa die Nachfrage zurück
war was dann wirklich ein sehr
schlechtes Zeichen wäre und den
Kursrutsch erklären könnte oder hängt es
eben mit Twitter zusammen verrennt sich
Mast dabei dem Kurznachrichtendienst und
verbrennt Milliarden vielen Dank nach
Frankfurt
und mehr zur neuen Ära bei Twitter gibt
es später in unserem heute journal
Update Nazan gökdemir hat Fragen an den
Blogger Sascha Lobo
kurz vor der Weltklimakonferenz hat sich
der Expertenrat für Klimafragen alles
andere als zufrieden mit Deutschlands
Klimapolitik gezeigt mit einem weiter so
würden die Ziele bis 2030 definitiv
nicht erreicht sagte die
stellvertretende Vorsitzende Knopf bei
der Vorstellung des ersten Gutachtens
laufe etwa der Ausbau von Solarenergie
zu langsam auch Wärmepumpen sein zu
wenig verbreitet und ein
Paradigmenwechsel nötig zum Beispiel
durch harte Grenzen für noch zulässige
Emissionen
zwei Wochen lang wurde bei einer
Konferenz in Australien um den Schutz
der Antarktis gerungen einen Durchbruch
gab es allerdings nicht die von
Naturschützern und Forschern dringend
geforderte Ausweisung neuer
Meeresschutzgebiete scheiterte erneut
auch auf strengere fischereimaßnahmen
konnte man sich nicht einigen um
Weltorganisationen zeigten sich
frustriert Schlüsse scheitern seit
Jahren am Widerstand von Russland und
China so auch in diesem Jahr
so und jetzt bei uns eine nasse
Erfolgsgeschichte 100 Jahre lang war die
Emscher Deutschlands dreckigster Fluss
kein Wunder wenn man bedenkt dass sie
sich einmal quer durch die größte
Industrie Region in Europa schlängelt
aber und das können wir Ihnen heute
zeigen eben auch nichts mit dem wir uns
abfinden sollten die Emscher entspringt
kurz vor Dortmund fließt durchs
Ruhrgebiet bis sie nach rund 80
Kilometern bei Dinslaken in den Rhein
mündet sie war ein offener Abwasserkanal
für Industrie Schlachtbetriebe und
Privathaushalte bis Anfang der 90er
Jahre damit begonnen wurde einen
gigantischen unterirdischen Kanal
entlang der Emscher zu bauen endlich
eine zeitgemäße Kanalisation
ein Meisterwerk der Ingenieurkunst
weltweit einmalig 5,5 Milliarden Euro
teuer und mit 30 Jahren Bauzeit dennoch
im Plan von der üblen Cloake zum grünen
Band Thaddäus Parade
hier bei Dinslaken endet sie die Reise
der Emscher hier stürzt sie eingezwängt
und begradigt über ein monströses
Bollwerk aus Beton in den Rhein noch
denn gleich nebenan darf sie sich schon
bald ausbreiten es ist der Schlussakkord
für die Wiederbelebung eines Flusses der
eigentlich schon lange totgesagt war die
Emscher die über viele Jahrzehnte ein
Abwasserfluss war wird jetzt wieder mit
dem rein verbunden das heißt hier
entsteht ein großes Mündungsdelta wo
Biodiversität Artenvielfalt aber auch
Hochwasserschutz zusammenkommen und es
entsteht eine Verbindung mit dem rein
rund 80 Kilometer weiter östlich bei
Dortmund ist der Umbau bereits
erfolgreich abgeschlossen statt stinkend
und eingezwängtem Betonbett schlängelt
sich die Emscher durch eine malerische
Auenlandschaft so kurvenreich gelingt
das nicht überall doch die Menschen
freuen sich über die zurück gewonnene
Natur
[Musik]
früher bin ich nie hier lang gegangen
nein aber jetzt wenn man sieht wie den
ganzen Umbau und alles das ist einfach
nur das ist schön das toll Anfang des 20
Jahrhunderts war die Emscher noch klein
und beschaulich doch Schwerindustrie und
die wachsende Zahl an Menschen im
Ruhrgebiet wurden ihr zum Verhängnis die
Emscher musste alles schlucken und
verkam zu einem stinkenden oberirdischen
Abwasserkanal der Bau von Abwasserrohren
unter der Erde war aufgrund des Bergbaus
unmöglich auf über 842 Quadratkilometern
ist die Erde um acht bis 28 Meter
abgesagt und diese Bergsenkungen haben
dazu geführt dass auch Kanäle unter der
Erde betroffen gewesen wären das
Abwasser von Millionen Menschen wurde
deshalb mitten durch die Stadtgebiete in
betonkanälen entsorgt und landete
schließlich in der Emscher
erst Anfang der 90er Jahre mit Auslaufen
des Bergbaus beginnen die Arbeiten für
einen gigantisches Abwassersystem die
größte bauliche Herausforderung ein
zentraler abwassersammler entlang der
Emscher tief in der Erde
Linda Pieper ist an der Emscher groß
geworden und nie fortgezogen früher
musste sie wegen des beißenden Gestanks
oft das Fenster schließen nun dreht sie
hier ihre Runde man kann sich das nicht
vorstellen wenn man den Fluss nur von
früher kennt und auf einmal sehe ich
enden und jetzt mittlerweile seit diesem
Jahr haben wir Frösche in wenigen Tagen
öffnen sich hier an der Mündung die
Schleusen erstmals können dann auch
wieder Fische vom Rhein mit Hilfe von
Steinstufen in die Emscher aufsteigen
und die einstige Kloake des Ruhrgebiets
mit neuem Leben füllen
faszinierender beweis es geht das war
unsere Welt an diesem Freitag im
heute-journal vielen Dank für Ihr
Interesse wir wünschen Ihnen noch einen
schönen Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend an diesem Wochenende startet
die 27
Weltklimakonferenz bei der der weltweite
Klimaschutz beschleunigt werden soll das
Klimasystem der Erde ist kompliziert
Ozeane Landmassen Eismassen und
Atmosphäre wirken ständig aufeinander
mehr Treibhausgase durch den Menschen
bedeutet es gibt auch mehr im erzsystem
gespeicherte Sonnenenergie wussten sie
dass von dieser zusätzlichen
Wärmeenergie die Lufthülle nur ein
Prozent aufnimmt der weitaus größere
Teil nämlich 91% fließt in die Ozeane
die wirken also wie ein Puffer und
verlangsamen die Erwärmung der
Atmosphäre aber das hat seinen Preis
wärmeres Meerwasser bringt zum Beispiel
steigende Meeresspiegel stärkere
Wirbelstürme Sauerstoffarmut und damit
Artensterben
nun kommen wir zum Wetter bei uns heute
Nacht ist im südlichen Bergland oberhalb
von 1000 Metern etwas schneemöglich denn
aus Südwesten kommt etwas Regen auch im
Osten gibt es viele Wolken anfangs noch
kräftigeren regen die Temperaturen
sinken auf 8 Grad an der See und ein
Grad im südlichen Bergland morgen
erreichen wir im Alpenraum 6 sonst 8 bis
13 Grad mit den höchsten Werten im
Norden denn hier sieht man auch am
häufigsten die Sonne es gibt Schauer an
der Nordsee mit einem starkbögen
Westwind im Süden bleibt es dicht
bewölkt mit etwas Regen und oberhalb von
1200 Metern etwas Schnee ab Sonntag ist
dann aber von Schnee nichts mehr zu
sehen das wird wieder zu mild für diese
Jahreszeit dazu gibt es etwas Regen im
Norden des Landes tschüss